[Music]
the highly anticipated beatdown between
godzilla and king kong has
finally arrived it's a mega dose of
monster action with a side of human
moments that maybe
aren't as good let's break down the best
and worst scenes in godzilla vs kong
don't worry king kong doesn't recite
shakespeare or start badmouthing
godzilla in the middle of their battle
but he has learned to communicate in a
very basic way in godzilla vs kong
he's vowed to protect a young deaf girl
named jia
a survivor of the ewe tribe on skull
island and has forged a connection with
her
gia converses with dr eileen andrews
through american sign language
and in a surprisingly serene moment in a
storm
it's revealed that kong has picked up
asl from jia
did the monkey just talk on the way to
antarctica
kong signs tajia on the boat that he
wants to go home
clearly he's not happy about being
chained to the deck of a cargo ship
it's a quiet moment before the bombastic
action
really kicks in and it gives the
audience a brief tender insight into the
connection between man
and monster it's arguably the film's
only moment of
genuine depth but it works a treat
ah madison russell you caused some havoc
back in godzilla king of the monsters
didn't you when godzilla vs kong picks
up millie bobby brown's plucky titan
enthusiast is away from all the monarch
madness and
attend school with her dorky friend josh
madison refuses to believe that godzilla
is out to hurt humanity choosing to
track down a paranoid podcaster named
bernie for insight
after picking up a few clues on bernie's
whereabouts and
learning that he showers with bleach
which is undeniably alarming
madison and josh show up at a
convenience store that bernie supposedly
frequents
and try to bribe the clerk for
information on the conspiracy theorist
the entire exchange between the three is
pretty painful to watch as the movie
attempts to
inject a dose of humor into the story
it's cringe-worthy
especially when josh slaps money down
onto the desk
and just feels out of place sure madison
josh
and bernie's story winds up leading to a
not so shocking third act reveal but the
trio are an example of the rather weak
writing behind most of the human
characters in the film
and this scene demonstrates that one of
the biggest
battles in godzilla vs kong is jiren
kong's journey to antarctica when
godzilla tracks him down while he's
chained to the deck of the cargo ship
the nuclear-powered behemoth quickly
decimates
most of the fleet gives kong a beating
and
even capsizes the ship in the process
with all the carnage taking place in the
open ocean
it's impossible not to feel just how
vulnerable
kong and the human characters are at
this point once the playing field is
leveled a bit
the punch-up really gets going and kong
gives godzilla
one hell of a beating it's the duo's
first confrontation and sets up their
conflict for the rest of the film
this scene also demonstrates how
director adam winger got quite inventive
with some of the supporting cast and how
they fight to stay alive on the
remaining ship while
two titans battle it out above and below
them
plus it's an incredibly cool scene to
watch but
you knew that already madison bernie and
josh's subplot gets
even more yawn worthy when the trio
starts sneaking around the ruined apex
cybernetics lab that godzilla attacks at
the beginning of the story
maybe we're thinking too practically but
they managed to make their way into a
secret sprawling
underground sector of the building
without being spotted
they're not exactly a stealthy group
either if anything
they're quite hapless
although the narrative is that they're
trying to uncover the shady research
that apex is conducting
madison josh and bernie spend most of
the time running between corridors
while bernie constantly talks about his
weird habits and obsessions
a movie called godzilla vs kong
shouldn't dedicate so much time to a
subplot for human characters that's not
really what the audience has signed up
to see
and though there's something to be said
about the lengths that the creative team
went to to add emotional stakes that
lead into the final
final battle this scene slows down the
film's pace
it's especially disappointing because
brian tyree henry is
excellent in atlanta and if beale street
could talk
julian dennison is excellent in deadpool
2 and hunt for the wilder people
and millie bobby brown is excellent in
stranger things and enola homes
and their talents feel underutilized
here
when it's finally time for godzilla and
kong's rematch following their first
round of fisticuffs
hong kong is the chosen battleground
since godzilla shows up to the city
looking to destroy something developed
by apex cybernetics
once kong makes his way up from the
hollow earth armed with a powerful new
axe
their fight gets brutal neither of them
hold back
kong hacks into godzilla using the
dorsal fin axe
and the nuclear beast throws the
protector of skull island through a
number of skyscrapers if you have issues
with the overuse of cgi in the third act
of blockbuster movies then
godzilla vs kong might not be the film
for you but
it's hard to deny that the film's hong
kong fight scene looks
absolutely stunning it's drenched in an
array of neon lights from all the
buildings
making the various explosions and
godzilla's glowing eyes and atomic
breath
look that much cooler the sequence only
gets
more interesting when the long rumored
mecha godzilla shows up and devastates
the duo
while the fight has a pretty predictable
ending it's still
a ton of fun to watch three behemoths
fight it out like they're the stars of
the biggest beat-em-up video game when
godzilla and kong's fight reaches a
violent crescendo apex cybernetic ceo
walter simmons
unleashes mechagodzilla in an attempt to
ensure that humanity is the only
dominant force on the planet
but it's really hard to take damian
beshear's character
seriously when he's the living
personification of the
mustache twirling villain stereotype
simmons spends most of his screen time
drinking whiskey and waxing lyrical
about his creation and not
caring about the natural order of the
planet that's supposed to be his biggest
personal concern
it's safe to say that doesn't exactly go
well for simmons and his own demise
comes from the very thing he created
in a last bid at shocking the audience
it's revealed that mechagodzilla
runs off a very specific power source
the consciousness of king ghidorah from
godzilla king of the monsters
it's an unnecessary addition to the film
that only raises more
questions about the practicality of how
technology works in this world because
it's all getting very futuristic
but then again this is a movie about a
nuclear fire breathing lizard and a
massive monkey wielding an axe
so why not godzilla vs kong may not be
the kind of film to win any oscars
but its energetic fights and the sheer
scale of its action
make it an entertaining watch check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one